I'm going to take care of you
[Music]
[Music]
it wasn't like being famous I'm not
famous yeah okay
this is grief counseling
anyone's invited to speak
people meet me and they think she's the
woman whose nephew
survived the plane crash
but they forget I'm also a woman who
lost my big sister
I wait outside
what are you doing drinking champagne by
myself out of a Juice Glass
lost my husband I lost my best friend he
had another life so I don't know how to
piece it all together
after I got to 200 I lost count
why does everyone writing to him
because he survived
I know you want to run away I want to
run away too but life has to go on
I don't know who I am join the club
[Music]
I'm sure you've heard great things oh
you know no secrets in grief group
of Grandmother paved the way and there
is no one more committed to carrying on
her Legacy than I am
[Music]
what happened isn't fair Edward but I'm
going to do my best to take care of you
and that is the truth that will never go
away